vitrine vélo maillot rambouillet est aux
couleurs du tour de france dimanche 28
juillet la grande boucle fait escale
dans la cité royale à l'occasion du
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
une première depuis juillet 2012
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail
mais l'équipe aille sont naturellement
et puis un une centaine bonne centaine
de bénévoles
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée est
renvoyée tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs nationaux
le rendez vous a attiré plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs sur
cette journée l'occasion pour ces
aficionados du vélo d'approcher les
coureurs qui les ont fait vibrer cette
année on habite en région centre
on a pas d'étape à côté de chez nous
donc on est obligé de faire deux heures
de route pour venir les voir
j'espère rencontrer beaucoup de coureurs
que j'aime bien que je voudrais avoir du
vent - parce que à la télé c'est bien
d'y voir billets de vendus
c'est encore mieux celui que tout le
monde veut voir c'est lui et gagne
bernal à 22 ans le coureur colombien est
presque assuré de remporter le tour de
france avant le départ à rambouillet il
doit juste terminer l'étape
un résultat qui enthousiasme les
milliers de supporteurs colombien
présent dans les éviers je suis très
très heureux c'est l'un des plus grands
jours de m
c'est une joie très grande c'est la
première fois qu'un sportif colombien
remporte le tour de france c'est quelque
chose de très important et nous sommes
fiers de représenter notre drapeau et
notre pays une fois les signatures et
laissez-les fit terminer direction la
ligne de départ pour les spectateurs
pour voir le départ de la caravane et de
ses 160 véhicules décorés aux couleurs
des marques
les coureurs s'élancent ensuite à 18h10
depuis le parc du château de rambouillet
et en direction de paris
les yvelinois reverront le tour de
france l'année prochaine
une convention a été signée par le
département pour accueillir la dernière
étape de la grande boucle jusqu'en 2023